i will read from your book to give
people an overview and by the way write
previous to this question i just wrote
down a wonderfully
philosophical set of sentences from you
which was about bryce and john
when you met them and then you felt the
pain of their absence you then wrote but
it isn't the absence that causes sorrow
it is affection and love without
affection without love such absences
would cause us no pain for this reason
even the pain caused by absence is in
the end something good and beautiful
because it feeds on that which gives
meaning to life
if those of you who are watching are
listening
i've recommended only one book
consistently and that's ian mcgill
christ's master in his emissary and i'm
going to start to add a second one and
that's order of time
it's filled with firstly if you want to
know about the nature of time and how
time has been thought of and redefined
or not well
recontextualized is a better way of
thinking about it
it's
it's a wonderful wonderful book and it's
quite short so the opposite is ian
mcgill chris which is i think
a tome and then yours is a compendium
it's quite
digestible
okay let's get to thermal time so
firstly i want to
tell you how beautiful
that set of lines were
thank you very much good thank you for
saying that about uh the audio of time
is it's definitely the book which is uh
that i have written which is more close
to my to my heart because uh
it's a book and you know the quotation
you you mentioned uh uh
shows it um
it's a book in which i talk about
science
it's mostly about science uh and it's
about the science of time and uh and i i
sort of try to summarize everything we
know from science about time
and also the things we don't know uh
about time from from science so
it's a big part in which i just
explained that best as i understand
uh what we've learned about time from
special activity from statistical
mechanics from boltzmann et cetera et
cetera for quantum gravity
um
and then also
the open questions uh what we think the
speculations
but there's also a book
when i wrote it
time touches us right
we are time is not a neutral thing for
us because
it's what makes us living but also what
we lose time is losing
so time is something that touches deep
us inside so it's it's a book that while
writing it i had constantly this
emotional aspect about time in mind so
there's a little poetry in the
verses from
horus which is an ancient latin
philosopher which i love which talks
about time the time that passes the
passage of time and there's a last
chapter in which i talk about death
which is the ultimate confrontation with
time that we have in our in our uh in
our life so it's a it's a book which is
science but also
uh our emotional relation with time as
you um
since the quotation you mentioned about
uh about pain and sorrow of losing
people
all right so sorry for this that's right
in chapter 10
i think in chapter 10 it's called
mandolin i don't recall the words that
came prior to it but it's about the
eastern mystic from the 100 years 100
first century sorry second century
nagarjuna is that correct
yeah nagarjuna is a chapter well no
there is a chapter in the guardian in
helgeland my book on quantum mechanics
okay so what was being referred to in
mandolin when oh this person said that
there is no eye
oh yes yes yes yes that's a famous
dialect in eastern literature the
beginning of the buddhist
philosophy it's a spectacular dialogue
the dialogue about the char chariot
right
who is he speaking to
uh it's a king king oh i've got the name
sorry i forgot the name
it's it's a it's a it's it's one of the
topics you want to dis discuss the
nature of i the self
um but let's go let's keep that for
later
so you asked about terminal time yeah
okay for the people who are listening
the links to carlo rivelli's book order
of time as well as his latest book are
in the description
and well what was super interesting to
me is in 2022 i'll start to delve a bit
more into eastern philosophies i've had
on pretty much zero although most
people's philosophies are influenced by
different parts of the world to some
degree
so this it was fun because when i was
first asking you for an interview
i used it as an opportunity for me to
learn loop quantum gravity
because i've always wanted to learn some
of that so i started going through your
lectures
but then i
was sidetracked in the most
positive manner by order of time i just
i just i didn't think that you were such
a philosophical person and they thought
boy oh boy i don't
well i don't know of anyone who
is
a theoretical physicist
that
is able to be so
cognitively flexible in that regard you
mentioned max tegmark but i haven't
looked him up much so i was just
i was thrown by that and i was i'm still
super excited to be speaking with you
thank you coach um thanks a lot um
so you want to know about thermal time
so can you explain what thermal time is
this is my question and then i had uh
some notes so the conventional logic for
interpreting this relation is time
gives you a notion of energy which gives
you a notion of a macroscopic state now
you're saying that this can be reversed
okay now that's so using that as a
jumping off point and remember that the
audience understands what entropy and so
on is
though if you want to quickly go over
you're more than welcome to
okay perfect so um
um
there are a number of open questions
uh in understanding time
i think there are a lot of things we
have understood
that time doesn't work with the way we
usually think about because we have
understood this with special
relativities general activity with
statistical mechanics but then there are
some open questions
and
among the
open questions
it's following
once we go
to
a generality relativistic description
about the world
um
the so
description of the world large enough to
include the relativistic properties of
gravity
then the theory we use
does not have a lot of variables
variable things we measure
but none of this
is naturally identified as a time
variable
that's the point
and i'm not talking
for those who are uh more learned among
those who
you guys who listen i'm not talking
about in a given space time
which one is a time of course in a given
space time there's the clocks that
measure proper time along each line we
know this time
but i'm talking about the
evolution of space time itself i mean
the einstein equation
that evolved for gravity space-time
matter everything
in that evolution
this evolution is given as relative
evolution of variables and not evolution
in
time then case by case we can identify
say well let's
call this type
one one particular variable this works
um in fact this is the way the world is
at the level of of generativity
and also at the level of a general
relativistic quantum field for quantum
gravity i think there is something funny
and that's a question
in our experience it's very clear uh
which variable is time it's it's the one
that clocks are connected to okay the
the time variable is completely
different than the other variables
profoundly different
and
so how is it possible that from a theory
in which no specific variable is
temporal then
for us
uh
one variable which is the position of
the clock is definitely completely
different than the others because it
distinguishes past from the future in
such a way
so i
worked on that
and i wrote some papers several papers
on that and a key paper with a french
mathematician field medal alain khan a
spectacular and brilliant and good
mathematician
because we got to this idea
both of us
independently in a very different path
and we wrote this paper together
he came to that from pure mathematics i
came that from think about physics
and so the idea is a speculative idea
i'm not sure is correct uh it's not
something people agree upon but i put in
the book that's a as a speculation it's
something i i think in some sense should
be right
um and there is a following
that uh
when we distinguish the time variable
from the other
it's because
of of what peculiar time what is
peculiar of time that the past is so
different from the future okay the right
and left are not different up and down
are not so different a little bit
different but we understand that
uh past and future are completely
different
and
but the big difference the the many
differences which we can write down but
the big difference is that entropy grows
toward the
future okay and this is a reason
we remember the past and not the future
this is the reason the future feels open
this is a reason uh uh uh if you if you
if you if you sure feel backward the
moving backward is obviously backward
and so on and so forth
so
what characterize a time direction is
not mechanics is entropy and entropy
means statistical mechanics and means
uh
uh that we're giving a course grain
description of the world in terms of
temperature entropy so with many degrees
of freedom and we are
um
we are um
uh
uh not describing all of them but only a
few of them this is what entropy is
about so there's something about the
flow of time which has to do with the
fact that um
we don't describe the microphysics we
have this macroscopic description
now if this so
then
it's very tempting
to
reverse the story
between the flow of time
and
the
macro physics okay in in the following
sense
uh
we learn in in physics textbook that the
time passes okay systems automatically
equilibrate because of the second law of
thermodynamics so they go toward
equilibrium
and when they go where they go to
equilibrium they go to a state which is
an equilibrium state and this
equilibrium state
is described
in the physics as one particular state
in the sense of
statistical mechanics a probability
distribution of all possible
configurations
okay so the logic think of the logic
time passes
and this determines a particular state
now the idea
alain and i
uh
got independently is that maybe this is
the other way around
we're getting wrong
since in the fundamental theory there's
no preferred time but there are states
right there states because
because we don't see the details of the
world we have an approximate description
of the wall so we give a description of
the world which is a a a statistical
state a distribution of a possible
configuration
now given a flow of time it it
detect determines one particular
distribution maybe we should
view the other way around given
a probabilistic distribution of the
world what we know about the world
this determines the flow of time you can
mathematically compute it that way
from the
distribution you can do a simple and
our paper will wrote down these
mathematical passages
um
we
statistical state of the world produces
a type variable
and
this is the idea of terminal time
and anaconda pushed this father
because
um
if you have a quantum mechanical system
by necessity
you have some randomness because quantum
mechanics randomness because if you
remember x and p
you you you don't commute and this
non-commutativity implies some
randomness
so
one of the big big mathematical results
that alan cohn has
obtained
is that
using this randomness
he could show
that any state
in the sense of quantum mechanical uh
states
determines a flow of time
and i don't want to enter into the
complication of const mathematics is for
neumann algebras complicated stuff
in some sense uh this evolution is
unique in some very peculiar senses
evolution is unique
so what khan is saying that
automatically once you have the
randomness of quantum mechanics you have
a time flow
the terminal time idea is is a simpler
version of that it's just if you don't
know the details
your lack of knowledge of the details is
such that mathematic is sufficient to
pick up a specific time flow
okay
so uh you see
if you study general relativity
the question is uh
which one
of the variables do you want to call
time variable
and the answer is well they all priority
the same but
if you don't know the details and you
have a foggy version there's one which
is preferred
and let me give you
if i have one more minute on this
question kurt
a simple version of this story
um
in special relativity
you have many time variables because if
you move uh
if you and i are moving respect one
another we have different lawrence type
in the lawrence information there's t
and t prime there's different times
right
they're all the same it's not one it's
better than than another they're all the
same okay
but
suppose you have a cloud
which is hot when you go out in the
universe and the cloud is hot
if it is hot
okay if you have a number of particles
that they move there is no preferred
time but if you have a hot cloud this is
hot and it has a temperature
which is determined by the fact that it
gots in equilibrium with itself
but it cuts in equilibrium in one
lawrence frame not in all lauren's frame
it's it's equilibrium in the frame in
which the
the cloud as a whole the center of mass
of the of the cloud is is is stationary
it's only in this frame that the
distribution is the distribution is the
the boltzmann distribution that you
expect
from the
so if you know the distribution if you
have a macroscopic description of that
you pick up a time i preferred lawrence
time
so you see
microscopically
you don't see any preferred time but
macroscopically is one preferred time
and the idea is that that's exactly what
happened in the world i mean we we live
in a world we interact with the world
macroscopically
obviously there is a past in the future
obviously there is a
a time direction
but that's because we use these
macroscopic variables if we were
really
interacting with all the degrees of
freedom at the level of generativity
all variables we will be equally
temporal variables
okay so let me see if i can understand
this and you can correct what i'm saying
time implies energy implies macrostate
as we talked about before
and then you can reverse that but then i
see that as a trade-off between
precision so if we were more precise we
wouldn't see time that's where alan
which i'm going to mispronounce but the
french mathematician you mentioned the
fields medalist alan connis that's
elaine konis that's where he comes in by
saying
clearly you can never be extremely
precise anyway given quantum mechanics
so that's why
quantum mechanically you can just you
can induce time in that regard does that
correct okay correct exactly exactly so
let me stress that it's a beautiful idea
i love it
i think it's right but i'm not sure it's
a very speculative idea so i'm i i
people have been complaining about that
and it's i think it's an open question
what are their complaints
so
um
the complaint is that the main complaint
is that
it's not
developed well enough because
[Music]
it
in an equilibrium situation
you need an equilibrium situation to
single out the time value
but actually
what we really
what really
what we really do in our life when we
pick up a time variable is precisely
because it's not an equilibrium
situation the past is different from the
future
so in a sense
it would be good to extend this uh
thermal time outside this simple
equilibrium case in which past the
future the equilibrium we don't
distinguish anymore
um
past and future to to make this story
really completely coherent